thrilled to have right here on the rich
eisen show
two gents that are in a film that is
everywhere where there is a theater near
you 12
mighty orphans in a theater starring in
part luke wilson and martin sheen
and both right here together on the rich
eisen show how are you luke and martin
very great thank you good to see you
guys so
um martin i'll i'll start with you
um what uh what what attracted you to
this film for you to be part of it
well it was uh it was a pleasure to have
been offered a
role that i could so easily identify
with right off the bat
with dr hall then to discover that it
was a real character
and then that it was set in one of my
favorite periods that that
uh that has fascinated me the the whole
uh
uh great depression in the united states
in the 30s
uh so i was disarmed and absolutely
uh uh uh delighted
with the offer and i i couldn't wait to
get there and uh
luke you play rusty russell in this film
who is the coach who is taking these
orphans putting them on the field
and creating modern football at the very
same time
and i'm wondering how you got prepped
for this
role um well i mean i'd always uh
i'd always been really into i'd i read a
lot of biographies a lot of like
music biographies but oddly enough over
the years i'd read a lot of
coaches books and i i don't follow like
high school basketball but i read like
a season on the brink by john feinstein
about bobby knight which was just
incredible and then
read about john wooden and then also you
know good football stuff about daryl
royal
and so i had always been interested in
coaches and just
you know how they kind of interacted
with their players
and just that you would have generally
an older guy dealing with all these
kind of younger characters from
different towns and cities
and families and just kind of how
you know different coaches approached it
like you'd have somebody like bobby
knight who's kind of a
maniac i don't even know what you could
call it tough love
and and then you have somebody like john
wooden
who seems like this kind of kindly
professor who managed to somehow
like get the the most out of these
players that
you know would have come from different
backgrounds than him and through the
tumultuous like
you know late 60s and he just kind of
managed to
to get through those times with such
success and
yeah i was just always kind of
interested in in coaches and
uh and i've never gotten a chance to
play one so yeah it was really
exciting the idea to get to play
somebody like that and martin i'm
wondering
how many sports films you've ever been
part of in your
illustrious career yeah to call this a
sports film
no i had two of my kids as you know uh
charlie did uh
major league and eight man out and
emilio did
three of uh the mighty ducks uh
and the in this current series it's on
now uh
about the mighty ducks but no this is
the first one
so it's about time it's basically what i
guess for you and your family for you to
catch up hey yeah yeah
you know for you to for you to get up to
speed here yeah and then
you know and then it's just the thing i
love about uh a film
like this one is obviously the the
historical nature of it
and just lines like uh in the film where
you know you luke are telling a player
to line up a few yards behind center and
they're like what do we call this i'm
like we'll call you the quarterback like
oh okay
and then you know and then we see what
what's what's happened
obviously since then i just loved the
whole evolution
yeah i mean that's what's kind of
exciting to me is it had me thinking
about like you know
football's like it's not an ancient
sport you know so
these guys were cam coming up with these
kind of
different offenses and defenses and it's
like i can still remember the first time
i saw like the no huddle offense and it
was the same thing like
you know what are these guys doing that
they haven't had a huddle they're going
they're going straight to the line of
scrimmage and
um yeah how people can kind of
revolutionize
revolutionize a game with these kind of
different ideas
and martin what what would you say is
your favorite sports film
from history excluding your sons
obviously
oh but is there any anything that you
you've watched
uh before or any uh
boy there were two films that we we were
very anxious to see one was
uh because i was a caddy you know i
started caddying when i was a boy so i
loved
uh golf i learned to play golf as a
caddy and so when
follow the sun came out with the ben
hogan story he was my hero you know
roberts and i i was watching all of the
pros
uh i i saw most of the pros of that era
but he was the only one that i never saw
play i saw snead play a couple times and
and so many of the uh that
the current champions in the 50s and the
late 40s but
i never saw ben hogan so i wanted to see
that film yeah and you know
that has there's a there's a downside to
it and that is if the actor
is not good at the sport you know it
kind of it spoils the illusion
and doug ford uh doug what was the name
uh
who played uh can you remember who
played yeah now it was
uh glenn ford linford
lady grant they would cut to him
swinging to ben hogan actually swinging
from the back
but you could tell that you didn't know
how to get a golf ball
yeah that's a tough swing that's a tough
swing to have to try and mimic where did
you
where did you loop martin where did you
loop growing up in dayton ohio
at the dayton country club no kidding
and so what what's the lowest you've
ever shot
in your life uh i broke 75 once
when i was 15. and luke are you still
playing
you're still getting out there yeah i've
not given up the game yet rich i'm still
playing
you're still committing it that's one
way to put it still committing him
committing golf
playing that draw okay yeah it's like
you mentioned sports movies and it kind
of makes me
it makes me laugh because like it's not
like ever doing a romantic comedy or
anything i ever like felt pressure about
the great romantic comedies that came
before but definitely
doing a sports movie i find myself
thinking like okay there's hoosiers and
slap shot north dallas 40 and all these
kind of movies that you do love to where
if you've grown up loving those movies
and being affected by them
i definitely thought about it while we
were making this
sports movie 12 mighty orphans in
theaters near you i'm a few more minutes
left here with
luke wilson and mark sheen here on the
rich eisen show i also couldn't help but
notice
that robert duvall is part of the cast
martin i am mandated to ask you at any
point in time
did did you stroll on the field asking
the players if they love the smell of
napalm in the morning did that ever
happen
you know i asked bobby uh it's a great
pleasure to
see him once again and actually play
with him because i hadn't played with
him since apocalypse but
i'd see him every now and then but uh
gosh that he
we had just a little window as luke
knows and ty roberts uh
said well we might get him we might not
so we didn't know until the day he
showed up and
and so we're just so honored to see him
again and play with him because he's one
of the great actors of
my generation but uh i adored him
personally and and
just to see him again i had butterflies
working there's just that tiny little
scene
oh jesus you know and uh
i just remember having that day off that
day off and going to work
and coming around the corner and there
was was martin and robert duvall
talking and it's like just i mean it
makes you go back to where you feel like
you're sitting in a theater and
i don't know what it's like for those
guys to have a bunch of guys kind of
looking like
lovingly at them but just while they're
trying to talk and catch up but it was
it was so incredible
and heartwarming just to see these guys
that you admire
so much kind of touching base and to see
how much they
they cared about each other and just you
know what they would have gone through
you know together you know in the
philippines back then
yeah yeah i was like gonna you know i'm
glad you said that luke because i
wanted to know what you thought you know
at any point in time like oh god
that's martin sheen and robert duvall
you know i know that you've done a lot
of films but you're not a jaded
individual that's pretty neat
to see and i asked that did you just did
just as a favor to me just say that line
once
there was a there was a moment in the in
the film when one of the kids is thrown
out of the game or takes a hit
and and and bobby would say uh cheer up
son
and i said you've got to say that like
you did in an apocalypse so he did so uh
i got to uh encourage him to do that oh
that's it
i was going to ask if the character's
name was charlie if he was not allowed
to surf or anything like that
you know and uh it is just uh it is just
a awesome
to see and i'm glad that you you had
that moment with with robert duvall is
there
any memory of that scene in particular
that we
as film fans don't know about martin the
day that that scene did
in fact take place the scene in
an apocalypse yes sir you've seen an
apocalypse
the most impressive thing about it was
that
uh we couldn't practice with the
choppers
they you know it was when they came on
the scene that was when we filmed and
that's
so we would practice the choppers would
be on the ground
and the blades would be still and there
was a guy standing by each chopper with
a long
a bamboo stick and if you got close to
the tail
he would he'd just start swinging at you
that's where
guys get killed you know he's backing
into the tail of a chopper on the ground
so so so and when the and so we would
practice our lines but then the scene
would start
you couldn't hear anything you couldn't
see for the smoke and
and the the the the sand kicking up
and there was bobby and he never missed
a line
or hit a spot i mean
it was like just follow him whatever he
does just follow him
he knows what he's doing you know the
confidence he he he just
oozed like the character that was bobby
in the middle of all those crazy scenes
he was very strict
you know the bombs are going on
it was it was mesmerizing just to watch
him
in those scenes he just never stopped
well it's just wonderful to see you guys
back on the screen together
and luke i'm assuming the same thing
with bamboo same thing happened on the
set of uh
of the old school right where they hit
you
there was chaos on old school white is
life-threatening
fantastic uh look luke it's great to see
as a coach in this film and it's just
great it's a wonderful story and the way
you guys
uh are part of a terrific cast and
telling the story i i can't wait for
everyone to see it
uh in theaters near you starting today
12
mighty orphans starring in part luke
wilson martin sheen thanks
guys for being on the show i really
appreciate it thank you rich really
appreciate it
better thank you for being on again luke
and martin i'd love to have you back on
i'll go further down memory lane with
you as much as you wish
thank you that's right here on the rich
eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here